maybe gentlemen and ladies how are you
doing on this euphoric evening welcome
to flappy fedora the game that finally
alright then the game that finally
represents my unique style goddamnit the
game that represents my unique style and
represents how I feel about [ __ ] how I
feel about life in general mutilate and
Yuma ladies and human ladies out there
who love them and Yuma ladies out there
who love an alpha male like me and want
to be rescued an alpha male like me and
wants to be an alpha male like me and
wants to be rescued from the Neanderthal
the neanderthal Neanderthal weakness
bait is out there on the Internet don't
let them talk down to you like that let
it let a gentleman [ __ ] let a gentleman
show you [ __ ] my euphoria levels are
dropping significantly man you guys
don't even know what it's like below you
don't even know what it's like to live
my life to be Who I am to be burdened by
my intellect god damn it you guys don't
even know what it's like to be free you
guys don't even know what it's like to
be buried [ __ ] you guys don't even know
what it's like to be burdened with my
intellect my level of intelligence
trying to find a pure to debate with is
just impossible did it's all you lovely
ladies out there remember remember the
next time you wanna remember the next
time you want a fashionable man look up
a man such as look up a man such as me
stylistically speaking I am going to be
your best better I'm gonna be your best
back going into the future just remember
I've got style class and a mind that
would eclipse yours any day because as
oh because as an alpha male I am at the
top of the food
I'm at the top of my intellectual pool
and I'm always willing to come to the
defense of you ladies on the Internet
people out there can be rather frack all
those beta males who just want to get
into your pants
all those beta males I want to get to
know you on an emotional level I wanna
know who you are
inside and I it's not that dirty way no
I will defend you to the ends of the
earth because I imagine ah because I am
a gentleman nice meeting gentlemen
because I respect women so much I've got
tons of female friends but if you just
want to be my friend that's not okay you
should recognize me for the gentleman
and rather attractive person that I am
I've got a lot of style and I've a lot
going for me
I am technologically savvy incredibly
intelligent and obviously I'm good at
video games so maybe you should just
give me a trance God give me a chance so
maybe you should just stop jerking
around them nice guys and stop putting
me in the nice guys category anyone god
it's just steps up putting me in the
nice guy category just cuz I come to the
defense of women doesn't make me a nice
guy I am sexy - I want you know oh you
know you know you know I'm a sexy
attractive guy both on the outside and
on the inside oh I am a catch I'm a
catch no matter what way you spell god I
am a catch no matter how you spin it
I'm an alpha male I'm super into oh god
damn it yes I haven't done anything with
my life really doesn't mean I'm not
going to I'm very intelligent
I'm just not motivated enough if I
actually start putting my brilliant mind
to use you guys would see that I'm
really the best one out there I'm the
best catch you can't get any better than
me
not with those neanderthal ik dum Rosie
you like to hang out with ladies or
Milady's those neanderthal ik bro dudes
get you always liked to hang out with
you know they're not better than me
they're not better
in any way look at me okay look at me
hey why you got to be going out with
anyone else on me you know that I'm
always gonna be there for you you know
you don't have to keep putting me in the
friend zone not the friends don't even
really exist but it kind of tells you
means you got to admit it you guys are
you got Yui you ladies kind of leave me
are you my ladies comes back he lets me
up be fashionable be fashionable society
end of the day just understand that I'm
on your side but if you don't oh my god
if you don't treat me right I'm not
gonna be on our side much more I'm not
gonna come to your defense when you need
me the most
I'm not gonna be the shoreland you're
gonna cry on when you're going to your
oh your boyfriend was bad to you oh no
no but I mean you know you need to
understand that I'm gonna be there for
you
every day I'm gonna be here for you all
the time I'm gonna be there for you when
you need me the least I'm gonna be there
inside your house I'm gonna be looking
in your windows watching you to make
sure you're safe when you sleep I'm
gonna be in your closet just to make
sure that I'm always there when you need
me I'm gonna be in your shower just to
help wash your back in case you need it
so just God give me a chance I'll be
like your best friend we're best friend
come on please give me a chance I swear
to god I'm gonna if you don't I'm gonna
milady milady euphoria it's awfully
euphoric day don't you think so just
talking is just please just I I do never
don't I my house the veil okay